Om du springer snabbast och du gör rätt saker, då kommer du vinna.
Gör du fel saker och gör dem långsamt, då kommer du inte existera snart.
Det är väl det jag känner att jag har jobbat de senaste 15 åren med, att se till att jag hela tiden optimerar för de två komponenterna.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni har omsätt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Evelyn Kaup till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Och Evelyn är ju Chief Product Officer på Cliro.
Och Cliro är ju betalbolaget som ska utmana Klarna och Svea, eller kanske redan utmana dem.
Men det som jag...
Snart, snart ska du få hoppa in i podden här, Evelyn, men det som jag tänker på när jag bokar detta var att vi sågs på ett event här för ett par veckor sedan.
Cliro gör ju en del event och då sa vi att vi är båda ansiktsblinda, så att vi...
Jag bara tänkte att om vi hade kört detta live så hade vi bara gått förbi varandra i korridoren och sen så hade vi...
Det var tur att vi hade en länk här.
Ja exakt, exakt.
Vi passar bäst i undanjömda rum där vi inte behöver socialisera med människor.
Välkommen till podden och hur är läget?
Tack så mycket.
Jo men det är toppen.
Lite grått och tråkigt väder idag, men sommaren kommer väl så spåningom, tänker jag.
Ja, du har ju en meritlista som är sådär lite halvskrämmande.
Jag tänker...
Alltid när man kollar på...
Jag och min fru nu med er, så vi kollar alltid på sådana här datingprogram, du vet.
Giftar vi förstögonkastet, sånt där.
Och då säger alltid, typ hälften av alla kvinnor där säger alltid, ja men män är lite rädda så för mig, eller they find me intimidating, säger de ju på engelska.
Upplever du att folk tycker att du är lite intimidating?
Du har ju i princip plöjt av varenda hypebolag vi har i Sverige.
Nej, det upplever jag nog verkligen inte.
Jag har ju plöjt av väldigt många hypebolag.
Jag gjorde det dock när de inte var så hypeade.
Så jag känner mig personligen inte så jättekul när jag blickar tillbaka.
Även om jag inser när jag går in och kollar på CV-t att det kanske är många fancy-loggor där.
Men nej, det är ingenting jag går och känner att folk hittar på.
När var Spotify inte coolt?
Nej okej, den kan jag väl hålla med om.
Jag gick nog faktiskt till Spotify för att jag ville vara någonstans där det var coolt.
Men jag var på Spotify i lite mindre än ett år till och med.
Så där var jag inte så jättelänge.
Men absolut.
De var definitivt hypade när jag var där.
Men du har betat av Klana, Spotify, Nordnet.
Sen hade du ett eget bolag där också.
Men det är ju tre rätt hypade bolag.
Varför hamnade du där?
Var det de som sökte dig hela tiden?
Eller var det du som liksom bara, det här är up and coming?
Det är väl lite olika tillfälligheter som gjorde att jag hamnade där.
Jag tror att det som gjorde att jag klickade med de bolagen var att det fanns en tidlig riktigt ambitiös nivå av att man skulle gå och ta över världen i princip.
På alla ställen, lika så på clear och nu.
Jag trivs ju när ambitionsnivån är nästan vad det kan kännas liksom orimligt hög.
För det är då man också kan vara orimligt innovativ och få göra de stora satsningarna.
Om man då kollar på alla de här faserna där jag kom in i de bolagen.
Så var det ju ofta, det var ju på Klarna tiden så var Vagelskladde fortfarande blått.
Och mindre känt på den tiden.
Jag var tvungen, jag minns att jag var tvungen att förklara för folk att när man handlar på ad libris så kommer du någon gång behöva betala.
Och så sa ja jo exakt, ja men exakt det.
Det är Klarna, det är som när du betalar.
Folk förstod det var lite halvbra, men det var liksom, man var fortfarande tvungen att förklara det på det sättet.
Men man hade ju enormt stora, stora ambitionsnivåer att man skulle ta över världen, man skulle bli ett starkt brand och man skulle ha varenda handlare i hela världen.
Och likaså på Nordnet-tiden, då var ju Nordnet mest uträknade.
Kom ihåg att jag pratade lite senare med några Avanza-människor och Avanza är ju den största konkurrenten till Nordnet.
Man i princip hade liksom rens drykigt Nordnet som en konkurrent från listan.
Men man hade en jättestor, man skulle köpa sig ut från börsen, man skulle totalsatsa och vända bolaget och verkligen positionera det.
Ett av de stora.
Så det var väl då jag blev taggad på att komma in där.
Och likaså nu på Clido, av att vi ska definitivt ta över världen och vi ska flyga långt.
Sådana saker blir jag taggade på.
Det är väl din gemensam nenne.
Är du tråkig i privatlivet då?
Får du...
Får du ut din...
För jag kan uppleva att det är så att jag...
Vad ska man kalla det?
Jag gör mycket i bolaget och tar mycket risk och sånt där.
Så jag är precis skittråkig privat.
Men är du sån?
Jag är helt annorlunda privaten än vad jag är i arbetslivet, det skulle jag nog säga.
Jag är inte den som är initiativtagare, utan jag gillar att få en liten softpotatis där, mer.
Så att om man behöver nog få ha det, man kan liksom inte gasa på alla delar samtidigt.
Sen har jag ju två små barn idag, så det går ju inte att inte gasa med småttingarna hemma.
Så vi har ju en hel del där.
Men jag försöker liksom hitta lugnet i hemmet.
Jag försöker alltid inte fastna i såhär barnsnack och privatsnack, men det är den stora nackdelen med barn, är att om man försöker ta det lugnt med barn så blir det jobbigare än om man inte tar det lugnt.
Det är ju den stora paradoxen.
Det är citatet som jag försöker förklara varje gång när någon säger såhär, ja men ska ni verkligen få en utflykt igen?
Om man bara, ja men alltså sitta hemma framför, bara sitta och rita, det är tufft.
Det är exakt, det kommer balla ur mer.
Då är det fönare att gå ut liksom i skogen och bara få springa av sig tillsammans.
Men har du alltid varit produktansvarig i någon form på bolagen?
Nej, utan jag började min resa faktiskt.
Min bakgrund är att jag pluggade finans och ekonomi.
Det var min pappa som tyckte att det var en stabil utbildning och jag hade inte så mycket synpunkter och tyckte väl om matte så jag tyckte att det kändes väl rimligt.
Jag läste ju fem år finansstatistik och väldigt mycket data och började också inom kreditsanalys på Klana i början.
Men jag märkte att jag inte är så bra på att sitta i det dagliga arbetet och bara göra, utan jag blir sjukt frustrerad när jag fastnar i någonting och tänker, varför är det så här?
Varför har man inte löst det på det här sättet istället?
Så jag började driva 600 projekt och inte göra det jobbet jag egentligen hade.
Då var det någon som till slut sa, men du ska nog inte göra det jobbet som du gör, det är du nog ingen vidare bra på, utan gör det här jobbet istället.
Då flyttade jag över till produkt.
Jag kommer ihåg min första vecka som produktägare, då tänkte jag, men undrar om de förstått att jag får berätta för folk vad de ska göra och jag får komma på grejer, och jag får bygga dem och jag får betala för det här.
Sedan dess går fudskänslan av att jag har hittat det absolut rätta jobbet, den har jag fortfarande, jag tycker att det är det roligaste som finns.
Jag tycker att det är ganska tydligt, jag har ju sett dig på två event, jag vet inte om jag har berömt dig på båda, jag har ju bara träffat dig de där två gångerna, men det är ju väldigt tydligt att du tycker om produkten.
Normalt sett när man går på sådana här event, så kan jag tycka att det ganska ofta är någon marknadsföringsnisse som ska prata om produkten, och då pratar man ofta om såhär, ja den ger 10% mer konvertering.
Så det är ganska sällan man får in någon som verkligen är produktpersonen och som kanske framförallt är, vad ska man säga, engagerad i produkt, på det sättet, inte bara står och babblar ett Excel-dokument och det är ju väldigt tydligt att du är produktdriven.
Är det bra, kan man ha en sån som ansvarig?
Jag förstår att det är bra att sådana personer finns, men om man ska leda ett team då blir inte det lite konstigt typ.
Du menar att jag är så enormt fokuserad på produkterna att jag är glömt med teamat?
Ja exakt, dels att kanske delegera på fel sätt, dels att fokusera på detaljer istället för helheten, dels att, hur går det där ihop?
Jag tycker det är jätteviktigt.
Jag hade det väldigt svårt för första gången som jag blev chef och inte skulle utföra själv.
Jag älskar ju att utföra själv, fortfarande idag, det vet alla som jobbar med mig.
Men jag tror att det viktiga där är ju att, det viktiga är att inte göra det hela tiden.
Och det viktiga är att dela intresset med de som man har i teamet.
För att om man är passionerad kring, min passion är slutanvändaren, den som kommer få produkten i handen.
Att kunna hitta den här produkten när man känner att här finns det ett behov, vi gör den här produkten och det bara liksom passas av handen i handsken.
Ett riktigt liksom, så fantastiskt.
Det är ju den bästa känslan som finns.
Och den känslan har ju många produktmänniskor och jag är bra på att rekrytera också människor som delar den passionen.
Och gör man det då är det ganska kul att få co-create och göra det tillsammans.
Jag älskar ju som ledare att göra det tillsammans med mitt team, inte hela tiden.
Det är ju ohållbart och inte så kul för någon av oss kanske.
Men att få dela den passionen då, då växer man ju tillsammans.
Vilket gör att jag får få utvecklas hela tiden i det yrket.
Men också att jag kan hjälpa dem som kanske inte har 10 års erfarenhet och har gjort alla de misstag som jag har gjort genom processen till att lite snabbare uppfatta, men vi kanske inte ska gå den här riktningen, låt oss testa det här och kunna förklara det.
Så jag är nog en som ledare som också är väldigt hands-on och springer bredvid teamat och får med dem på det sättet.
Jag vill gärna snacka lite om den processen sen, för den är ganska spännande och går egentligen igen på alla bolag.
Men om vi tar lite till om dig och din bakgrund här, du har ju varit några år på respektive bolag, kan man säga, och sen så har du liksom gått vidare.
Vad är det som har slutat vara intressant, eller vad är det som inte brinner längre liksom?
Jag älskar ambitionsnivåer, och jag gillar väl en specifik fas i ett bolag.
Jag älskar fasen av att man kommer fram till att man kanske har tuffat på ett tag, och sen bara, men vet ni vad, nu gasar vi.
Vi bara, nu ska vi ta över världen.
Det ögonblicket när bolag inser att vi ska inte bara sitta här och sakta köra, utan vi har varit ambitioner, det är då jag ofta vill komma in.
För det tycker jag är kul.
Och då brukar du ofta vara såhär, vad gör vi nu?
Total chaos.
Organisationen behöver ställa om till att gå från att bara göra det dagliga arbetet till att plötsligt hitta nya processer.
Vad betyder det att ta över världen?
Bryta ner mål från, ta över världen kanske betyder ta över Europa först, först kanske Norden innan dess.
Liksom, vara Sverigeledare, bryta ner målen till att okej men vad betyder det att vara Sverigeledare till det?
Hela den processen älskar jag av att strukturera upp ett stort ambitionsmål nere i små komponenter och sätta en plan till hur ska vi nå dit.
Börja se till att man får rätt team på plats.
Få teamet att fokusera, få teamet att jobba som ett team.
Ta reda på, okej, steg nummer ett.
Vad betyder en steg specifikt i sin lilla komponent?
Det betyder att vi behöver ha en app som konsumenter älskar inom betalningar eller vad det kan vara.
Vad älskar konsumenter när det kommer till det?
Och bryta ner det i de små delar.
Så hela den processen av att sätta upp den strukturen, det är teamet och en tydlig roadmap som kan stanna över flera år.
Det tycker jag är kul.
Jag tycker det är kul att se att det börjar snurra, maskinneriet springer.
Sen så kan jag känna att då jag har slutat har det varit när jag har ansett att vi typ har vunnit.
När jag slutade på Nordnet så var Nordnet definitivt en stark konkurrent i Avanza.
Om inte i vissa kopier hade sprungit förbi Avanza.
Från att vara helt utslagen egentligen till att vara där uppe och börja, vem är det som faktiskt är bättre?
Då kände jag att jag behöver inte springa om, utan jag vill komma upp på samma nivå.
Likadant är Klana.
Klana hade gjort en helt fantastisk resa under de åren som har tagit över många marknader.
Man kände att Klana kommer troligtvis att existera många år framöver.
Då kände jag också att då är det nog dags att testa någonting annat och göra exakt samma resa.
Det var där vi är på Cliro idag också, eller har gjort under de senaste tre åren.
Där hade man stått ganska still och stampat och lite tappat sin identitet eller sin tydlighet.
Till att nu har vi jobbat jätteåret på att få en bra ambitionsnivå, tydlighet i vart vi är på väg och stäffa upp rätt tid för att kunna springa i den riktningen.
Okej, jag trodde fördomsmässigt att det du gick igång på var att nu har vi fritt spelrum.
Du verkar beskriva det som att det roliga är att sätta upp hela processen och stanna där för att komma dit och det är ramverket för det.
Jag trodde att det nästan var tvärtom att det som du gick igång på var att man får prova allt möjligt eller man får, det finns ingenting som är förbjudet för vi ska bara se vad som funkar.
Jag kan uppleva att det är den fria delen av det.
Det är den fria och jag tror att människor som har jobbat med mig vet att jag inte är den personen som kommer med en massa processer och är processorienterad men jag vet att det finns steg som behöver tas för att vi ska ha rätt riktning i den friheten.
För det värsta jag vet är när man bara flummar.
För man kan ju också bara, man kan ju säga nu ska vi ta över världen och så kan det bli liksom flum, flum, flum.
Det betyder att vi börjar lägga till något helt nytt segment och så springer vi åt ett annat håll.
Men jag älskar när man vet exakt vad man ska göra och sen är ju den här kreativa processen av att man får skapa och testa för att komma dit.
Men med tydliga mål så att man helt enkelt kan mäta att man är på rätt väg och inte svävar ut åt fel håll.
Vad är det du är bra på?
Du har ändå blivit anställd på de här olika, du har ändå kommit in på de här olika bolagen och blivit anställd i den här fasen.
Absolut att du är passionerad med produkt, men det är väl fler människor som är, och du är ju inte ens produkt från början, du är ju finans, så vad fan.
Ja, men det är en jättebra fråga, du undrar det också.
Speciellt den här gången när jag undrade varför jag fick betalt för det här jobbet.
Men det är två saker som jag bryr mig väldigt mycket om, och jag tror att de flesta bolagen inser att det är det som är värdefullt.
Jag tror att det enda som spelar någon roll i det vi gör är att säkra att man springer snabbast och att man springer rätt.
Jag är väldigt bra på, under mina år har jag jobbat med att optimera för att man ska springa snabbt och vi ska springa rätt hela tiden.
Med det menar jag att, okej, hur springer man snabbast?
Man springer snabbast för att vi ser till att man skapar ett fokus i bolaget.
Vi prioriterar på rätt sätt.
Vi gör det som jag kallar alltid korta korvar.
Nu betyder det att hellre sätta många personer på att göra en sak snabbt och få ut värde än att sitta här en person på vad det är grej och sen så bara sitter man och fumlar i 16 år som ett projekt som lanseras.
Så att korta ner projekt så mycket som möjligt.
Och sen så att hela tiden se till att man inte bara går och funderar för mycket på de stora sakerna utan att man tydligt vet att nu fokuserar vi på att göra det här, vi gör det klart, sen kollar vi på nästa grej, vad krävs för att göra den?
Bra, då gör vi hela djupdikningen och sen levererar vi där.
Så att man verkligen strukturerat tar sig framåt steg för steg för steg för steg till det stora målet som man har och inte svävar ut för mycket.
Så det är komponenter som jag ser är jätteviktiga i att kunna springa snabbt.
Alla, det är så många bra bolag därute överallt, i varenda industri, så det är så enormt viktigt att vara snabb.
Då kommer det till den andra komponenten.
Man måste vara snabb men man får inte vara slarvig.
Det spelar ingen roll om du har världens snabbaste organisation där alla deployar och skjuter ut nya produkter, en liten titsamt tätt.
Utan då är det andra viktigt att det är rätt saker som kommer ut.
Där jobbar jag jättemycket med mina team om att vi ska vara så enormt insiktsdrivna som vi bara kan vara.
Alla olika datapunkter, vi ska prata med sälj, vi ska prata med kundtjänst, vi ska sitta och kolla på internt data, vi ska ut och intervjua kunder, vi ska vara ut och för oss också intervjua handlare.
Bara gå på evänt, få idéer därifrån, få så mycket insikter som möjligt, som tillsammans hjälper oss att ta beslut om att vi gör rätt saker.
Om du springer snabbast och du gör rätt saker, då kommer du vinna.
Det är ju det som spelar roll.
Gör du fel saker och du gör dem långsamt, då kommer du inte existera snart.
Det är väl det jag känner att jag har jobbat de senaste 15 åren med, att se till att jag hela tiden optimerar för de två kompetenterna.
Det är en bra svar.
Det är logiska svar.
Jag tänker att det är svårt att illustrera på en intervju eller på en...
Jag gillar korta korvar.
Det är så här...
Fan vad professionala.
Då förstår vi ditt tänk.
Jag köper...
Vi jobbar ju en hel del.
Vi sitter i ett magentosystem till exempel.
Då är det också viktigt att man jobbar på det sättet.
Att det inte blir ett enormt projekt för då kommer det aldrig att bli klart.
För att det kommer komma en ny.
Det är ju också det som är...
Personligen, det finns en egoistisk take i det hela också.
Och det är att jag tycker att det är jävligt kul att jobba på det sättet.
Det är ju kul att göra rätt saker.
Och det är roligare att göra någonting snabbt än att sitta på ett vattenfallsprojekt som tar liksom två år.
Och sen så vill de inte fira ett slut längre.
Man har kommit i mål för man har så tröttnat att man har suttit med den här dumma projekten i flera år.
Ja, exakt.
Om vi tar de här check-outarna på marknaden idag, vi säger clear och svea, klana, det finns väl någon Wall-E-grej eller liknande och Paypal.
Alltså det finns ju massa olika betalcheckouts.
Kan du uppleva att det är lite frustrerande att om ni till exempel lägger ett halvår på att komma på en funktion och så märker ni att det här ökar konverteringen med tre procent, då kommer ju konkurrenterna snor det inom typ en kvart.
Är det inte så?
Alla ni måste ju ha stenkoll på varandra för att i slutändan handlar det väl om konverteringsprocent-typ.
Är det så att ni alla sitter och bara live-streamar varandras live-uppdateringar hela tiden?
Och är det frustrerande?
Det tror jag nog att det händer väldigt mycket.
Vi försöker att kolla väldigt lite på konkurrenterna och istället fokusera väldigt mycket på användarna.
Vi får egentligen, check-outerna därute har alla kanske sina för-
och nackdelar.
Mycket är också likt för en normal människa som tittar på det, som kanske inte är nördar ner och säger lika mycket som vi varje dag med det.
Det är ju min andra fråga sedan.
Vad fan är skillnaderna egentligen?
Men, börja med den första frågan.
Det största värdet vi kan göra är ju att vi ser den vanliga människan som tar sig genom en betalprocess, hur den tar sig igenom på bästa sätt istället för att snegla på våra konkurrenter.
Vi försöker verkligen att titta så lite som möjligt.
Sen är det ju en liten värld så att alla snegnar nog på varandra.
Blir man irriterad?
Nej, utan det är väl ganska förväntat när det släpps någonting som är bra.
Så det är ju snarare en komplimang, tycker jag, varje gång som det är någon som kopierar en.
För då har man ju varit först och man har gjort någonting som någon annan inom samma yrke som vi tycker, oj, det där var ju snyggtlöst, och så kopierar de det.
På så sätt så driver vi ju varandra framåt, vilket också är personligen varför jag älskar paymentsindustrin.
Det är ju hög konkurrens och lite som liksom, jag har ingen elitserien liksom av att Champions League i princip, i att varenda lilla fel och snetramp kommer kostan.
Därför blir ju de här två komponenterna, återigen så pass viktiga, att man måste göra rätt, och man måste göra så snabbt som möjligt.
Och vi är ju väldigt snabba nu på Clero, så vi har jobbat väldigt hårt med det.
Där känner jag att då kan vi springa framför och så kan konkurrenterna kopiera, men det kommer att ta tid för dem att kopiera också.
Känner du inna konkurrenter i branschen, vet du vilka som är ansvariga för ungefär samma områden hos konkurrenterna?
Ja, inte alla, men en hel del har jag jobbat med tidigare.
När ni ses på gatan, snackar ni och kan slappna av eller är ni såhär sura på varandra?
Nej, vi kan snacka och koppla om, men ofta blir det lite trash talk.
Ja, såklart.
Lite, precis som det är i sportsvärlden egentligen.
Det ska jag ha så.
Men okej, om vi tar, och du får vara subjektiv här, vi förstår ju att du inte kommer säga att att Kliro är sämst på bla bla bla.
Men liksom, för mig då som en vanlig människa, eller till och med, jag har ju för fan en e-handel liksom, jag tycker ändå att många grejer ser jävligt samma ut.
Vad är, vad är liksom de stora skillnaderna mellan check-outer idag?
Och har ni olika fokus eller är det bara att det ser lite annorlunda?
Vad är liksom på riktigt skillnaden?
Det finns ju olika lösningar.
Det finns ju vissa, jag blir ju till exempel skitförbannad när jag kommer till en personligen, när jag handlar, jag handlar ju mycket om det här.
Och så blir jag skitförbannad när jag kommer till en annanstans.
Innan du säger vad det är, så bara känner jag att jag blir nog inte lika förbannad.
Jag tror att du kommer att känna det när du förstår vad jag säger.
När man behöver fylla i alla sina detaljer.
Men gör man det fortfarande?
Det händer väl aldrig längre?
Ja, nej men jo!
Det här och jag, jag, jag...
Det känns som en sån där grej som folk som jobbar med check-outer säger.
Fåfarande säger?
Nej, jag kan hålla med om det.
Däremot så handlar jag, det kanske också är en arbetsgada, men jag handlar ju nästan i princip allting online, så man kan handla.
För att jag tycker att, så då hamnar man ju fortfarande på sådana check-outer.
Ska jag säga, med det sagt liksom, det är ju inte de som kanske är de stora, stora konkurrenterna därute.
För att gör du det, då är du, då är du ju riktigt illa liksom.
Så är man en e-handel därute och lyssnar på det här, och man behöver ange sina uppgifter igen, då bör man nog se över sin check-out.
Eller postnummer i ett visst format, eller plus 46 innan telefonnummeret bara byter.
Ja, nej nu går vi vidare här.
Okej, men det finns total skit liksom, det är dom.
Men annars skulle jag säga att alla vi och våra konkurrenter har lite olika takes och tweaks.
I vilken roll tar vi i ekosystemet?
På Cliro fokuserar vi på att vi vill vara en finansiell accelerator för våra handlare.
Vi vill hela tiden se till att vi driver kunderna tillbaka, trafik tillbaka till handlaren.
Så i alla ytor där vi kan skapa att slutkonsumenten återigen påminns eller uppmärksammas om e-handeln du var inne i, så vill vi driva tillbaka.
Det är vår take på det.
Du menar till exempel när man har lagt en betalning eller när man går in och betalar, då ska det vara enkelt att gå tillbaka.
Jag fattar vad du menar.
Efter att du har lagt en betalning, så låt oss säga så här, du är inne på e-handeln, då lägger du en betalning.
Det ska ju bara gå så smidigt som möjligt.
Det känner jag så här, det observerar vi nog alla för.
Ni är ju väldigt passionerade kring just det och tycker att vi är väldigt duktiga på det.
Efter det kommer en efterköpsupplevelse, om man till exempel som konsument har valt faktura eller någon typ av betalningsena.
Då kommer du tillbaka in i till exempel Kleros app, eller så kanske du får ett mejl av oss.
Då vill vi så mycket som möjligt påminna om, kom ihåg att du köpte de här skorna, du kanske vill också köpa en matchande t-shirt, eller hela tiden se till att vi driver tillbaka till den handlaren som du kom från.
För att påminna om den relationen och på så sätt hjälpa till att bygga lojala kunder.
Vårt fokus är ju verkligen, vi kallar det bara flywheel concept, att vi hela tiden vill sluta cirkeln av att så mycket som möjligt i alla ytor, driva tillbaka trafiken till e-handlaren.
Men det är våran typ.
Där har vi också aktivt valt att vi ser slutkonsumenten som en användare som är handlare och slutkonsument.
Så vi har en relation naturligtvis under transaktionen och vi har en relation när du kommer in i clear och appen och sånt.
Men vi gör det ju för handlaren.
Vi vill skapa, vi tar hand om dem och vi värnar om dem för konsumenter är det finaste som finns.
Det har vi gemensamt, men vi gör det för handlaren.
Jag älskar den strategin, för den är en tydlig strategi som vi följer.
Medan vi har andra konkurrenter och spelare i marknaden som till exempel snarare sätter sig på konsumentens sida och då skapar en fantastisk konsumentupplevelse där de prisjämför, visar de bästa erbjudanden, men då kanske till bekostnad för handlaren för att man blir jämfört mot andra.
Det finns för-
och nackdelar för det för handlare också.
Jag tror att det är jätteviktigt att när man väljer en checkout idag, om man då ska kolla på skillnaden mellan de som finns i Norden just nu, att man försöker förstå hela livscykeln av ens slutkonsumenters resa och hur den kan skilja sig åt i det.
Men är ni inte rädda, jag fattar ju den distinktion, en grej som jag tänker på som jag inte vet ifall ni gör eller inte, men det finns ju sådana där du som kund så skickar du tillbaka och då kan du avbryta köpet i appen till exempel innan varan liksom har kommit tillbaka.
Är det en sådan funktion då som ni kanske inte skulle godkänna då för att e-handlaren kanske inte vill hålla på så?
Jag tror att alla e-handlare resonerar till att de vill att sina kunder ska vara så nöjda som möjligt.
Så om vi ser att det finns ett jättestort kundbehov där det faktiskt också kan finnas en bra kundresa, för just den där är ju också väldigt svår att få till en bra kundresa på som funkar liksom för alla.
För vad händer om du redan har skickat iväg varorna?
Då kommer de igen att komma fram och då blir du skitirriterad av att du faktiskt klickade på den där knappen liksom.
Om det finns en stor kundbehov och man kan leverera med en bra produkt, då är det ju definitivt någonting vi vill göra för att vi vet att våra handlare vill att vi ska göra det för att vi ska göra det bästa för deras konsumenter.
Men vi gör det för att vi vill att våra handlare ska ha jättenöjda slutkonsumenter.
Fokus är e-handlaren och inte sluthandlaren i små beslut hela tiden.
Det är ändå en intressant take på det.
Om vi bara lämnar hela att du jobbar på Klyro.
Om man ska jobba med att förbättra en produkt eller ta fram en produkt.
Jag tänker att du har jobbat med ganska många olika varianter här.
Det är det som gör det lite spännande.
Vad är det folk gör fel i den processen?
Eller vad är det man ska göra rätt i den processen för att det ska bli...
Du har en existerande e-handlare, en existerande bolag och du ska driva igenom ett förändringsprojekt på något sätt.
Hur gör en smart människa liksom?
Det är absolut...
Man behöver gå igenom olika faser.
Den första fasen är alltid i alla problem man någonsin har.
Att bara ta ett styrk tillbaka och försöka samla in så mycket insikter som möjligt.
Och bara liksom, okej, jag ska lösa problem X.
Det är jätteviktigt att förstå vad är problemet och vad är liksom mitt mål med det hela.
Det är ju första.
Men då baserat på det, vad är de viktiga insikterna jag behöver göra kring allting runt omkring?
Och då kommer det tillbaka till exempel, jag är en e-handel och jag vill optimera min hemsida.
Då kanske jag behöver förstå högst troligtvis slutkonsumenten.
Och då gäller det att samla in så många olika källor som möjligt av information.
Man kan, man har säkert någon typ av tracking, så gå in på liksom historisk data och kolla på hur konsumenten har betett sig.
Man har säkert någon typ av kundsupport.
Ibland kanske man är den själv.
Så man liksom bara boilar ner vad är de stora frågorna som kommer där.
Man kanske har, man kanske till och med har någon typ av aktiva säljare ute.
Så man kan personer som säljer saker som man kan prata med.
Och du kan också bara sätta dig ner och ringa upp tio konsumenter och fråga hur upplevelsen var och intervjua dem.
Eller göra en sådan enkel sak som att gå ut på gatan och faktiskt bara hej du jag driver en e-handel och så här ser min e-handel ut.
Skulle du bara kunna ge mig två minuter av din tid och visa hur du skulle köpa ett par skor?
Och funka det liksom.
Jobbar du alltid så?
Jag bara tänker att ibland blir det så jävla mycket brus när alla ska ha en åsikt.
Och det är så mycket, jag fattar såklart om det är en stor grej men hur ofta går du bara på att det här är bara rimligt, nu kör vi liksom.
Och när får man göra det?
Ja precis, alltså är det större beslut?
Om det är så här, oj nu ska vi tänka om hela det här, eller nu ska vi göra en, vi ska göra om vår hemsida och sånt.
Då skulle jag säga, det känns inte så bra kanske bara att gå på magkänsla just där.
Där behöver det ju ett större arbete.
Men har du liksom, om du kontinuerligt gör den här insamlingen utav, alltså som jag jobbar i, när jag börjar på ny arbetsplats, då gör jag liksom den här 360, samla in så mycket data som möjligt.
Sen ser jag upp, sitter jag till att jag har bra forum för att jag kontinuerligt hela tiden utsätts för den datan.
Det kan vara att jag själv har blockat tid av att måndagar sitter jag och kollar lite i historisk data.
På tisdag går jag förbi kundtjänst och bara lyssnar vad de får in för samtal och sånt där.
Jag tycker det är jätteviktigt att hela tiden bara kontinuerligt få in det intrycken så att du inte sitter i din egna lilla bubbla medan världen utanför dig utvecklas.
Gör du det, då kan du definitivt gå på magkänsla i mycket av casen.
För du går ju inte egentligen på magkänsla, du går på insikter som du har samlat upp det hela tiden även om du inte strukturerat gör det just för den här frågan.
Men det är väldigt farligt ifall du liksom zoomar ut ett halvår, inte alls samlar in och har intryck och så sitter du där och wingar det för att du tycker att det borde vara så här för jag tycker det.
Och det kanske kommer till din fråga som du hade där i början av.
Vad är det man kan göra fel?
Och det är väl det största felet som jag ser när folk lanserar produkter.
Att de bygger produkterna bara för sig själva.
För att vi måste inse att vi är så biased i oss som individer.
Det kan vara att jag är en mamma och tänker annorlunda än kanske en en single tjugoåring.
Det kan vara att jag är kvinna och inte man.
Det kan vara att jag är en viss ålder.
Det kan vara att jag jobbar med teimens och stirrar på en checkout hela jävla tiden.
Och ingen annan i hela världen kommer att bry sig av att jag bytte knapp eller gjorde fonten lite större eller mindre.
Jag menar att jag tycker att det är en jättestor grej.
Jag går definitivt gärna mycket på magkänsla, men då är den ju också för att jag ser till att hela tiden få in influenserna längs med vägen.
Jag bara älskar att...
Jag tror att du hade hatat att jobba hos oss.
Ni bara kör magkänsla hela tiden.
Alla beslut tas ju på att det här tycker vi, jag tycker om det här.
Jag kommer ihåg när vi pratade på det här eventet, och då pratade du om hur du bara kunde dra ut och bygga upp ett gym hos någon eller vara med i en träningsbass eller kunna basta med dina kunder.
Där samlar ju du in insikter och det är det jag menar.
Det jag inte så strukturerar är att jag sitter och har en jätteagenda, utan längst med tiden så har det blivit exakt det där.
Jag älskar hur du snälltolkar att jag sitter och bärsar med några kunder.
Nej nej jag bärsar inte med kunder, jag samlar in data.
Det är exakt vad det är.
Du bara vet inte.
Du bara tankar in data varje gång.
Exakt.
Får man, hur mycket ska man, när du är i ett projekt, hur mycket anser du att såhär, förutsatt att det inte är en enorma projekt men att det är liksom en sprint eller vad vi ska säga.
Ska man då genomföra den sprinten och testa eller får man avbryta under tiden och variera för det kommer in nya grejer.
Liksom äga.
Vart går gränsen liksom.
Ja, alltså jag vet att det som gör att man springer snabbt och snabbt var ju viktigt.
Vad skönt att detta var en så tröttsam fråga, det var en sådan ja.
Det är ju att man är fokuserad och så gör man klart den uppgiften man har.
Det värsta som finns och det vet ju vi också, du sitter och har påbörjat en uppgift och det kommer någon att ställa en fråga och den frågan tar en halvtimme och så ska du fortsätta med det du har gjort.
Då har man ju tappat sitt.
Så är det ju för utvecklare också.
Om någon sitter och gör en sak och så kommer jag som produktmänniska och bara ooo kolla här, kan vi inte bara ändra font?
Då tappar de fokus och så har de tappat kanske dubbelt så lång tid för att de behöver komma tillbaka till kontexten.
Så det kostar jättemycket.
Och som produktmänniska så ska jag säga att man blir, för mig är en seniorproduktmänniska en människa som har känsla för det.
Man känner sig i team tillräckligt mycket, man vet vilka som är bra i teamet på att kontextswitcha och vilka som inte kan det.
Och man vet när det är läge att liksom skjuta in en liten högerboll här bara.
Men du den här va, vad tycker du om den?
Kan inte du göra den på istället för fika resten eller liksom här i slutet av dagen så kan du fortsätta imorgon med någonting annat.
Så den fin känsligheten är enormt viktig för att jag tycker ofta skapas nästan mest värd ut av sådana små puckar som ibland kan komma från sidan.
Det behövs just nu, det är superkritiskt, det går lätt att fixa.
Nu skjuter vi in den, nu kör vi bara.
Så de är superviktiga, det gäller bara liksom om det sker hela tiden, då blir man inte snabb.
Och så tappar man liksom siktet på vart man är på väg.
Ja, lite liknande på den är att jag fattar det här att man vill ha ett fokuserat team och att folk liksom jobbar åt samma håll.
Men hur mycket kritiska röster vill du ha i teamet?
I teamet, och hur mycket, det är ju jätteviktigt.
För att ibland ska ju folk bara sätta sig ner och fucking hålla käft och köra typ, men ibland vill man ju att de ska bara, nej nu är du dum i huvudet här, det här låter ju inte bra.
Nej, jag tycker att det är det du säger, jag tycker att det du säger, just för ditt språk, är väl så som jag tycker är väldigt viktigt att jobba.
Så det är ju viktigt att skapa.
Kan ni klippa ut det till någon arbetsintervju?
Ja precis.
Det är just det språket som uppskattas.
Om man säger håll käften i det här, då har de jobbet.
Men det är ju viktigt att man som team känner en sån trygghet, så att de som team, till mig, kan säga, men håll käften.
För när du har det, då är det ju trygghet över att de inte känner att de behöver sitta och hålla på någonting som är faktiskt viktig.
Sen kan jag tillbaka säga så här, nu skiter jag i vad ni tycker, nu kör vi liksom.
Men de går utifrån och inte är arga för det.
Det är väl det viktigaste.
Att man kan ha en sån bra dialog av att man har en dialog.
Den är öppen men den är timeboxad till att vi pratar nu och sen jobbar vi.
Det är viktigt att vara snabb och komma framåt.
Det värsta som finns är ändlösa konsensus samtal.
Det är så farligt som bolag om man hela tiden söker konsensus.
I svenska, jag har haft några kompisar som har flyttat till Sverige och blivit så chockade i slutet av möten i Sverige så blir det tyst.
I några sekunder i nästan varje möte är det tyst.
Man ska bara se, är det konsensus, kan vi avsluta det här mötet och gå vidare?
Men i andra länder, då är det såhär, bub på så går man ut genom dörren och så bubblar det.
Den har jag faktiskt verkat märka till att det ofta är så.
Men det är viktigt att veta när man kan avbryta och bara ta beslut och köra.
Hur funkar du som chef där?
Vad är din approach?
Jag har väldigt mycket tillit.
Jag säger till att jag ska ha fantastiska människor.
Jag har alltid med nu världens mest fantastiska team.
Då vill jag ge så mycket frihet som möjligt och bara förtroende till att de springer.
Men så vill jag att de ska dra i mig så fort de vill ha en riktning.
Så de kan komma till mig och gärna i mikropauser av såhär Evelin, två minuter, det här händer, det här händer.
Jag tänker såhär, kör eller inte kör och då bara kör.
För det är då vi, istället för att det blir såhär ja men ni får träffa mig en timme varannan vecka och så sitter vi och går igenom alla beslut och då ska jag sitta och titta på allting du har gjort med det.
Så mycket förtroende.
För att återigen är såhär för att man ska kunna springa snabbt, då kan man ju inte springa själv.
Utan då skulle det ju vara många som springer gärna i samma riktning, så fort som möjligt.
Och så kanske du är såhär, ja men vadå?
I 70% av fallen springer man i rätt riktning och allting är frid och fröjd.
30% av fallen missar man målet.
Men då har vi ändå gjort väldigt, väldigt många mer mål än alla andra som inte har sprungit huvudtaget.
Är det den tävlings...
Ja men det låter ju som en tävlingsgrej.
Eller du verkar ju gilla den här tävlingsaspekten av det.
Gulle du säga att ni liksom pitchar mot konkurrenterna?
Använder ni er av liksom konkurrenterna för att skapa en motståndare?
Hur mycket jobbar ni med det?
I intern till bolaget?
Ja.
Faktiskt ganska lite.
Jag tror att vi, fy, vi pitchar.
Off the record nu.
Det är bara med att få på den här.
Det är inte så många som lyssnar, kom igen nu.
Hej Kastan, hej Wally.
Nej, hej Fred.
Nej, jag, såklart att man liksom, vi vill springa snabbare än dem.
Jag tycker att vi springer väldigt snabbt och vi gör väldigt bra saker.
Det som gör, det jag vill, att mitt team ska vara mest förbannade över.
Ja, ha politiskt korrekt i det.
Ja, jag ser hur du anstränger dig för att säga rätt grejer här nu.
Kom igen nu.
Nej, men det som är arbetslöst är ju att vi gör rätt saker.
Det är ju det, att vi springer i rätt riktning.
Jag tycker det.
Om slutkonsumenten och omhandlaren är nöjd och slutkonsumenten är nöjd, vi vill ju inte, jag jobbar inte inom payments och med den lösningen jag säger att jag vill göra det alla andra redan har gjort.
Jag brinner ju för produktutveckling.
Jag vill ju göra de sakerna som ingen har gjort tidigare.
Och det är ju när jag får, när jag och lika som mitt team som är lika pensionerade som jag, det är ett jobbigt gäng.
När vi får göra coola saker som ingen har gjort tidigare, det är ju då vi får gå och är riktigt taggade.
Då blir man ju inte så taggade över att nu ska vi lansera det som konkurrenten runt hörnet precis gjorde och så kollar vi på dem liksom.
Utan vi vill ju bara springa våra till dig, så var det så här shit, det här är så här 100% av handlarna slog på den här featuren idag.
Alla älskar den och kolla, kunderna har skrivit på sociala medier av att shit, han vill testa Cliro och snyra det här.
Eller vad smidigt det var att handla med Cliro.
Eller jag älskar Cliro-appen, grymt team.
Då sitter vi och gråter här, det gör vi, för riktigt.
Jag undrar också vem som har den där rösten som du gjorde.
Det är någon på kulturhuset som har just den.
Men en annan grej jag tänkte fråga är, är det jobbigt att sitta i en ledare?
Upplever du dig själv som en ofrivillig ledare?
Det är ju uppenbart ett produktfokus att få göra de här grejerna.
Har du känt att jag tvingas lära mig ledarskap, eller var det något som du ville från start?
Och i så fall hur utvecklar du ledarskapet?
Ja, nej jag ville nog inte absolut bli...
eller det fanns för någon tid när man var väldigt ung som man skulle bli chef, för det var ju coolt att vara chef.
Men om man bortser från den tragiska perioden, så har jag nog inte verkligen sökt efter ledarskapet.
Men jag älskar att jobba med människor som är lika passionerade, som jag, kring det jag gör.
När jag är ledare så har jag lyxen av att jag får välja mitt egna team.
Och jag får forma mitt egna team och jag får också sätta aktivitansnivån av att det är så här bra våra produkter ska vara och våra konsumenter för den här produkten ska tycka det här.
Och tycker ni inte att det passar då är det här nog inte rätt ställe.
Så det tycker jag är sjukt lyxigt.
Och som ledare är jag egentligen en i gruppen som är lika nördig som alla andra.
Bara att jag har lyxen av att välja russinen och krakarna ibland.
Ofta brukar jag handla med skitmacka i knät istället.
Men ja, det tycker jag är lyxigt.
Och så tycker jag det är kul med unga drivna personer som är lika passionerade kring och vill lära sig och är nyfikna på att säga har du gjort det här någon gång tidigare?
Hur gick det den gången?
Och så bara oj, den gången det var inte bra.
Gör inte det, gör det här istället.
Hur mycket får man, har ni också ett så här 80-20-tänk typ, att ni jobbar med saker som ni vet?
Att liksom, är han, alltså så här, ja, det är uppenbart att designen är en viktig punkt och sen är det, ja, och så lägger ni några procent på så här riktiga jävla testskott för att se om det ens är någonting.
Finns det någon så här bra skala där som som du har märkt genom olika bolag?
Ja, jag har lärt mig att det finns inte, det går inte att jobba med en sån skala.
Absolut inte.
Vilket roligt svar.
Grattis, det är bara att göra det tråkiga.
Nej men det är så svårt.
Det finns ju alla sådana skalar av såhär, man ska lägga 80 procent på nyutveckling och 20 procent på att städa och göra teknik och rätt.
Det är ju skitsnack för att det gäller ju bara att se till att du bygger rätt när du håller på att bygga.
Och sen så när du bygger nytt så bygger du rätt och så bygger du bort det gamla.
Och på samma sätt så är det såhär, om man ska 80 procent göra de sakerna man vet rätt och sen får man testskjuta.
Då finns ju en risk av att du bara hittar på någonting som du testskjuta istället för att du testskjuter rätt saker.
Jag tycker att vi testar allt vi gör, det är ju bara att testskjuta.
Men det gäller ju att testskjuta saker som är hyfsat underbyggda med någonting.
Och ibland kan den där vara såhär, ingen har gjort det tidigare.
När man pratar med konsumenter så säger de ju någonting som typ är lite såhär och det vore riktigt jävla kul om det här skulle flyga, för det skulle kunna ge värde 1 för oss, för vad handlar det eller för någon.
Då ska man bara se till att det är jättekör, då kör vi.
Men du kanske inte bara kan satsa på sådana saker, sådana saker snubblar du inte över hela tiden.
Man har ju inte bara hundra sådana som ligger i bagaget.
Och har du det, då kanske du ska köra hundra sådana.
Förutav de hundra så kanske femtio är rätt, och då är de ju avskola mycket mer värde än att du sitter och polerar någonting.
När vet du att du har utvecklat klart en produkt?
När ska du sluta med?
För det går ju alltid att fila liksom.
Det finns ju alltid.
När är det bara slöseri?
När är det bara tidsödande?
Jag tycker det är en av de viktigaste frågorna som vi ställer oss så pass lite.
För att jag ser så många bolag som lyckas och så kommer de upp till en viss nivå.
Och sen bara tappar de sin identitet och vet inte vad de ska göra längre och sen så faller det och så blir de utsprungna om någon annan liksom.
Men då har du redan lämnat så då är det lite...
Ja, jag är inte kvar då för jag har aldrig börjat lösa det problemet.
Det är ett spannike sitt stru.
Men när jag tittar på de här då, historiskt i backspegeln och får följa med utifrån, så är mitt råd av att när man har kommit med en produkt där du, alltså det gäller ju hela tiden att sätta ett mål.
Och det är ju alltid livet liksom så här, men vi ska hitåt.
Du kan ju sitta varje dag och göra ett jobb utan att veta varför du gör det och inte ha ett mål till vad du ska göra.
Så den här produkten ska få i slutet av året tio miljoner nyanvändare, det kan ju vara ett mål liksom.
Men om ditt mål är liksom så, om du känner att jag har suttit med produkter vid tillfällen där det är så här, den här produkten är så jäkla bra, det finns ingen kopi längre som är rimlig att lägga på, då kommer vi bara lägga på en massa skit liksom.
Då är det dags att sluta.
Då är det dags att sluta i den formen av att då får du titta bredvid.
Okej men utifrån det här, och nu har vi den här positionen, och vi är marknadsledande och vi är bäst i det här, för det borde man ju ofta vara då när man slutar, då vad är de sakerna bredvid som är närliggande som skapar värde och där vi har kunskap till att faktiskt vara bäst i världen på att göra det här.
Och så får du liksom börja bredda dig åt andra hållet.
Och det är ju också kanske då det är bäst timing till att börja bredda sig.
Men jag tycker att man ska absolut hela tiden vara ärlig med sig själv och det är svårt.
För ofta behöver du ju liksom då acceptera att det är ett flaggskepp, det du någon gång har blivit bäst på i världen.
Det ska du överge lite.
Man måste ju alltid hålla koll för världen att utvecklas och du måste ju se till att den håller sig uppe och är bäst.
Men ska du börja överge lite och börja ta det ut i nytt land vid sidan om.
Så det är läskigt.
Det är många bolag som fastar och bara kanske hittar på att köra nya revenue streams.
Du skjuter in massa reklam i befintligt.
Typ som kanske Google kör, så du inte ens hittar sökresultat efter ett tag.
Så då börjar du förstöra din produkt istället.
Jag har försökt spara Kliro-snax, jag tar det nu på slutet, så att det inte ska bli för reklamigt.
Men ni gjorde en lansering eller en kampanj kan man säga, där ni sa att om ni byter till Kliro, och om vi inte konverterar bättre, så betalar vi er en halv miljon.
En miljon var det?
En miljon, okej.
Och då fick ni ett exa antal kunder, och det som var det coola där var ju att ni konverterade bättre, i alla fall, har jag för mig om jag inte har tagit fel.
Som tuvar.
Ja exakt.
Så undrar jag vem som kom på den idén, om du får berätta det, och hur jävla nervös den personen var.
För att det är en sådan, jag vet inte om du har sett på The Office, men Michael Scott i alla fall, för folk som talar på The Office, han har en sådan här golden ticket idea, och så lägger han fem stycken golden tickets, och så får folk halva priset när de bara skulle få tio procent.
Detta känns som en sådan som kunde liksom fucka upp ordentligt.
Dels hade det kunnat bli skitdålig reklam och kosta jättemycket pengar, men nu löser det sig.
Nummer ett, vem kom på det?
Nummer två, så undrar jag, man säger väl, det är ju jättesgenerellt att folk säger, klarna konverterar bäst.
Det har ju stått i forum i många år.
Är det liksom en gammal lönk?
Varför konverterade ni bättre?
Vad var det som var bättre på riktigt?
Lång jävla fråga.
Det var många frågor här som jag ska hålla reda på.
Nr 1, vem kom på det?
Du misstänker kanske att det var jag, för det var jag som kom på den.
Vi hade precis lanserat den nya check-outen.
Jag blev så förbannad för att jag behövde internt förklara för alla, att den här är jävligt bra, den kommer att konvertera bättre än i princip alla check-outer därute.
Och då var jag så här, ja men är det verkligen exakt det här?
Men klan har ju funnits jättemånga gånger, alla säger ju att det är bättre, hur kan du säga det?
Vilka är de här rösterna?
Varje gång någon ska härma så kommer sådana här.
Vi ska få träffa dem från de här skämmorna.
Nu kommer mina röster.
Men det var exakt.
Det var även skeptis med intern.
Det var nästan mer för att motivera säljteamet att verkligen pusha.
Jag fick ställa mig någonstans på ett möte och så blev jag jätteförbannad och så röt jag till.
Men snälla, jag har kollat på checkout den större delen av mitt liv och så började jag ranta.
Steg ett, vi gör det här.
Steg två, det här händer.
Det här ska faktiskt maximera konvertering på det absolut bästa sättet.
Och de satt liksom så.
Jag är så jävla säker att vi skulle kunna betta en miljon på det här.
Och då började ett smart marketing team som highade till direkt och ba ha, snyggt, det kanske vi ska köra en kampanj på.
Och då blev det lite svettigt för det var också någonting jag slängde ur mig i affekt i ett möte för att jag försökte ställa det inte.
Men vi diskuterade igenom det och såg exakt som det.
Det här kan flyga och bli riktigt bra, eller så kan det här gå åt skogen.
Och så sa vår vd Kristoffer Eberheim, ävelin, hur säkert känner du dig?
Är det 50-50 eller 80-20, i så fall åt vilket håll?
Så att vem ska veta vilken viss vi tar?
Jag känner mig ändå, kör vi tester mot alla ihop, jag känner mig ändå väldigt bekväm med det.
Jag kan inte säga 100%, att vi kommer nå varandra test, men jag känner mig ändå, majoriteten av dem kommer vi vinna.
Och då säger han, okej men jag litar på dig, och det är tillräckligt gott, så att vi ändå ska gå ut och våga köra den här kampanjen.
Och jag tänker att den tilliten är också enormt viktig att kunna få ha, vilket också är viktigt om man är lite tokig och vill testa coola saker.
Så då gick vi ut och testade, och så har vi vunnit alla AB-tester.
Och då kommer det till den här Klarna-frågan.
Och utan att, igen, alla tar olika perspektiv inom industrin, vad man fokuserar på.
Och under den tiden där jag jobbade på Klarna för väldigt många år sedan, då hade man ju också väldigt stort fokus på just handlareupplevelsen och konvertering.
Man sålde ju konvertering, det var jättetungt liksom.
Men sedan dess har ju också väldigt mycket utvecklats.
Och kollar man på en Klarna-resa idag, så är det ju väldigt mycket att du hoppar ut ur checkout-resan som är liksom inne på handlarsidan, då du länkar sig ut till en separat app eller webbversion och där händer det massa steg.
Och du länkas kanske därifrån till Swish och sedan hoppar du tillbaka.
Och alla som har jobbat med litetekniska delar vet att det där länkningen är jävligt svårt att få till.
Alltså du ska länkas ut och du ska länkas tillbaka och du ska göra det på ett snyggt sätt.
Och du ska göra det om du kommer från Instagram eller någon annan typ av social media-browser.
Likaså som du ska kunna göra det om du är inne i en gammal iPhone och bankidestrullar eller någonting.
Och varenda sådana grejer när du länkas så tappar du några konsumenter.
Och så har de också lagt till många steg för att de vill promta olika betalsätt och sånt.
Och jag tror att de har optimerat, eller jag ser ju det, de har optimerat för andra saker än just konvertering.
För att de också vill driva användning i deras interfaces och funktionär adaption.
Så good for them, de har gjort ett annat spår.
Men det gör ju också just de resorna, och det är ju inte riktigt klara idag, det är ju custom nu med ett nytt bolag som fortfarande har tagit över den check-outen och fungerar på ett liknande sätt.
Jag tycker det är en bra beskrivning att det som du egentligen tog bettet på utan att jag kan alla check-outer och sånt här, är att rent logiskt så borde antalet steg och hur strömlidning i form att det är gör att det blir bäst.
Det är det man bygger på, inte varumärket i grunden.
För det är inte alla som känner, no offense mot Cliro, men det är ju inte lika stort varumärke som till exempel Klarna, men det är inte det som i slutändan avgör, utan konverteringen sker av antalet steg.
Jag gillar det bättre, jag fattar, det är lite spännande.
Hur viktigt är då, det kanske inte är din fråga att svara, men Cliro har ju gjort, andra än att vi sitter här idag är ju för att ni har lite event och sådana grejer.
Ni har ju positionerat er lite som att såhär, men vi är heta inom checkout, det är vi som är the next thing.
Om det här stämmer så spelar egentligen inte varumärket på checkoutens jävla stor roll, så varför ska ni ens lägga pengar på det?
Ja att vi ska, vi behöver ju få komma i kontakt med någon som vill.
Kan ni inte bara ringa alla jävla e-handlare och säga att ni får en miljon om inte vi konverterar bättre?
Ja, jag är helt ärlig, och nu är jag helt ärlig.
Vi får se vad marketing tycker om det här.
Jag tror att vi tar detta på slutet när de inte orkar lyssna längre.
De bara, om hon verkar faj nu.
Ja det är bra.
Nu har den checkat ut.
Men vi behöver ju driva den förändringen.
Vi har ju en jätte i industrin som har varit marknadsledande i väldigt många år.
För att kunna döda det riktigt som du precis sa, så behöver vi få airtime.
Vi behöver förklara varför vi tror att vår läsning är bättre, eller varför vi kan se det, och varför vi kan känna oss bekväma med det.
Vi behöver komma upp som en top of mind, för att en av våra konkurrenter har ett enormt starkt brand.
Är man en mindre e-handel idag, då är det de flesta, alla e-handlare, alla som sitter och bestämmer hurvide man ska ta in och check out, är det också konsumenter som handlar online och möter olika betal lösningar och känner till den här konkurrenten till stor del.
För oss är det viktigt att bryta igenom ett varumärke på det sättet.
Man måste synas för att få existera.
Vi försöker ta någon mikrofon och skrika, här är vi och vi gör någonting fantastiskt och förklara hur fantastiskt det är.
Det var väl inte så hemskt sagt.
Nej, jag hoppas det.
Evelin, vilket roligt poddavsnitt.
Man tänker när man ska prata produktutveckling inom checkoutlösningar, så tänker man inte...
Tänker man, yeee!
Du tänker...
Du vaknar i morse och är bara, nu ska jag få prata produktutveckling med Evelin.
Stort tack för att du tog dig tid att vara med.
Jätteroligt att ha dig här.
Tack själv, det är jättetrevligt.
Jag bara älskar hur du snälltolkar att såhär, jag sitter och bärsar med några kunder, nej nej, jag bärsar inte med kunder, jag samlar in data.
Det är exakt vad du gör.